[Music]
hello and welcome to safety ridge on
sunday well it's been a bad week for the
reputation of parliament more than 50
mps reportedly being investigated by the
parliamentary watchdog for allegations
of sexual misconduct and this week the
conservative mp for tibetan resigned for
watching pornography twice in the house
of commons even if he says he was just
searching for tractors really not sure
that's the excuse that he thinks it is
and while huge global stories have
rightly dominated the agenda recently
the focus is momentarily shifting back
to uk politics with local elections
taking place across the country next
thursday this week on the show we're
having a bit of a pre-election special
with not one not two not three but five
party leaders joining us today
we'll be talking to the first minister
of scotland and snp leader nicholas
sturgeon we'll also be joined by the
labour leader sakir stama setting out
his pitch
for the government we'll be talking to
the business secretary kwazii kwante in
the studio in just a few moments time
and we'll also talk to the liberal
democrat leader ed davey
the co-leader of the green party adrian
ramsey
and finally there the leader of plaid
comrade adam price busy show busy show
today
[Music]
hello well the conservative mp neil
parish has resigned after what he's
called a moment of madness when he
admitted watching pornography twice in
the house of commons well it's certainly
not what conservatives want to be
talking about in the week before those
crucial local elections which after a
pretty rocky few months will undoubtedly
be seen as a test of boris johnson's
leadership and that's not to mention the
cost of living crisis something our next
guest will be acutely aware of he's
urging oil and gas companies to reinvest
the bumper profits they're currently
making to increase investment in the
north sea we can talk now to the
business secretary quasi
thank you very much for being uh with us
thank you sophie um i just want to start
off by talking a bit about the culture
in the house of commons um as we just
said in the introduction more than 50
mps apparently being investigated for
sexual misconduct of course had the case
of the conservative mp who's admitted
watching pornography twice
in the house of commons
is there a culture of misogyny in
parliament i don't think there's a
culture of misogyny i think the problem
we have
is that people are working in a really
intense environment
there are long hours
and i think generally most people
know their limits they know how to act
respectfully but there are some
instances
where people
don't frankly act uh according to the
highest standards and with neil um i
think he did the right thing he did
something which in most other
professions you would be sacked
for doing
and he voluntarily resigned and i think
his position was
very difficult
um as you say he has resigned but there
are wider accusations now there's a
wider look at what's going on
in the house of commons not just one
person and i just want to read you
something from the sunday times or all
the newspapers that have this kind of
thing
this morning but this is from the sunday
times
talking about some of the allegations a
senior mp accused of repeatedly licking
the faces of male researchers other
allegations include staff has been
groped in parliamentary bars by mps
female parliamentarians been subjected
to misogynistic nicknames even claims a
minister overheard having noisy sex in
his office
i mean what is going on have you seen
any of this kind of stuff no i've never
seen any of it it is extraordinary and
obviously it's completely unacceptable
and that's why we've set up only three
years ago
the independent uh complaints and
grievance scheme uh which allows people
uh to go to an independent body and
complain make complaints make uh serious
accusations because i mean when i came
in in 2010 there was none of that there
was no recourse all you could do was
complain uh to the person you're working
for which
in many cases would be the person who
was uh you know behaving badly on that
do you think that's something that
should be changed the speaker saying
today that he wants to look at the
system where mps directly employ their
own staff because you can see why it'd
be problematic absolutely so so uh as i
said in 2010 we had it we didn't have
any recourse at all 2018 we set up this
independent complaints and grievance
scheme which allows people to uh
complain to an independent body and i
think the the speaker and people like
dame andrew ledson are very good very uh
clear
that we need to see how we can improve
the current situation to be clear do you
think that
the mps should be able to directly
employ and be responsible for the hr of
their staff well it's not my
view not my opinion uh that matters in
this we've got the the speaker we've got
other people who are looking at the best
uh and the best practices
look i think that generally uh most mps
have have a sense of responsibility
um and i've had the same pa for 12 years
and i have a sense of responsibility in
terms of looking after staff in some
instances
i think people uh do uh acting
responsibly and that's why we've got
this independent uh uh scheme and it's
only been around for three years it
doesn't sound
um
like a short amount of time but it but
it needs uh time to really get get going
and actually it probably needs more
resources as well so you don't have an
opinion then on whether mp should be
able to direct employ staff i take your
point that obviously i'm sure the
majority of mps are fine but the whole
point is that you're looking at the
people who have behavior responsibly
yeah i'm not going to lurch to one
conclusion or another i think that what
the speaker said yesterday was that we
should look at best practice around the
world so that we can get the best system
so there are lots of different avenues
but clearly what's working
what we have now isn't working
sufficiently well um another thing that
some people are talking about is female
representation in the house of commons
oliver dowden the conservative party
chair has told the sunday telegraph he
wants to make sure in his words the
party's candidates list reflects the
fact that half the population are women
would you like to see 50 conservative
women mps i think we should have
certainly a lot more uh female mps just
as we should have more people from a
wider range in the conservative part in
the conservative party um again we've
made huge progress i mean i remember
when i was on the candidates list in
2003 there were no ethnic minority
conservative mps um there's been a huge
change in that but clearly uh there's a
long way to go would you like to see all
women shortlists i've never been a fan
frankly personally
of um quotas and shortlists i've never
really advocated that but obviously we
should do all we can
to see how we can get more women and
more people from diverse backgrounds
into politics um how about parliament's
bars is it acceptable that there are so
many bars in the house of commons should
they be shut no they shouldn't all be
shut i don't think we should have a kind
of uh excessively puritanical or severe
regime in that regard i think again i
would say people should be expected to
act
responsibly and if they don't uh we've
got we should have the process the
procedure uh to make sure that people
are sanctioned and punished i guess my
issue is listening to you you know you
condemn
some of what's happened and and you say
that you know we need to take action i
can't work out what action you think
should be taken uh you know you won't
commit to saying it would be a good idea
to look at how mps employ their staff
you don't want to look at parliament's
bars you don't want all women shortlists
so what i actually said because you were
trying to get me to do uh to advocate
one bit i'm just trying to work out what
you would like to change in westminster
in order to stop this kind of thing i
think definitely we should look at um
mp's practices you asked me a specific
question and i said that's what we're
looking into i wasn't going to give you
the answer because that's exactly the
question
that we're examining i think i've never
been a fan of quotas but i think we
should do all we can to encourage more
women
to come into politics and people from
diverse backgrounds from diverse
professional backgrounds from diverse uh
ethnic backgrounds uh and to reflect the
diversity in our in our culture okay
okay thank you
i'm keen to talk to you about the local
elections as well uh big votes going on
of course across the country next week
what would success look like for the
conservative party well look we're gonna
fight for every vote um clearly in a
midterm situation uh there is a lot of
pressure i'm not gonna give a number or
or say anything like that but i think
we're competitive i think i look back at
the 2012 local elections which again
were mid midterm very very challenging
um frankly at the moment i i think uh
you know we do face challenges but we're
in a reasonable place and i was speaking
to uh constituents on friday and i think
i think you know there's all to play for
um you say that there's a challenging uh
situation the latest salvation poll uh
shows the conservatives on just 34 with
label and 47 so big golf there and that
of course would put some of those key
councils at risk in places like ones
with places like berry some of these
flagship conservative councils are you
worried that you're going to be punished
for when voters look at what's happening
in westminster that you're going to be
punished for that at the polls in every
local election people
vote on a variety of uh reasons for a
variety of reasons and sometimes people
look to national politics i think
actually increasingly people do look at
the local
local situation you've got labour
councils such as croydon uh nottingham
who went bankrupt i think people are
very aware of the fact that labour is
not uh generally a good custodian of uh
public money um and labour councils have
gone bankrupt so they will people will
be voting on local issues how about in
scotland as well do you think labour
could overtake you to become a second
party in scotland i don't know um about
the situation uh in scotland i mean i do
follow scottish politics very closely
but we've been competitive over the last
few years in scotland we've done very
well actually and i'm hoping that we can
continue to do that so you think you
might be able to hang on to the second
place after that after the snp i hope so
i think that's what we're going to be
fighting for okay now we know of course
that some conservative mps have lost
faith in the leadership of boris johnson
because they've told us that they're the
only ones of course that we know about
because they're the ones that spoken
publicly about it
the local elections next week going to
be seen as a key test for boris
johnson's leadership if you perform
badly
could his leadership be a threat i don't
think his leadership is a threat at all
i mean what he's delivered is really a
remarkable series of successes i think
brexit he delivered on that um i think
the fact that he was uh very widely
appreciated in ukraine he's been widely
um held as someone who's led uh the the
ukrainian um effort the overseas effort
to rip to help ukraine and also look at
the vaccine rollout that was very again
a great great bit of no matter what
happens next week no matter what the
results are boris johnson is safe
absolutely you better tell jeremy hunt
according to the mel on sunday he's
about to launch his leadership jeremy is
a very capable colleague he's a good
friend
i don't know what he's up to but as far
as i'm concerned boris johnson is the
right man uh by far uh to lead us into
the next election are you concerned that
what he's up to might be gunning for the
leadership i don't know what jeremy
you'll have to ask him i don't know what
his plans and also lots of rumors uh in
westminster and i wouldn't necessarily
believe all of them okay and now
if it does go badly in the local
elections you talk about the challenging
picture this may be uh why i just want
to bring you uh this polling from yougov
which i hope hopefully we should be able
to see so they people were asked which
government would be better at
regenerating areas outside of london and
the southeast
17 percent
said the conservatives and boris johnson
38 said labour and kirstenberg like your
flagship policy is literally to level up
and people just don't believe you're
gonna do it well it's one poll and
that's why we're going out
uh to make the message clearer uh and
more focused and i think absolutely if
you look at what we're doing if you look
at somewhere
like uh ben hodgson's uh mayoralty in
the north east
t side there's huge amounts of
investment billions of investment uh
nissan who told us uh
they were reported to say that we were
they were going to leave uh the uk after
the brexit vote they've invested a
billion pounds they've announced they're
going to invest a billion pounds you
accept that the messaging needs to be
clearer and more focused do you i think
i think i think we're absolutely always
trying to make our message clearer and
more focused and we have uh a number of
uh months
to do that ahead of uh any prospective
future election we're absolutely focused
to get the message out there and the
results are pretty tangible i mean you
know as i said billion pounds uh from
nissan we've got british volts who are
making um uh batteries for electric
vehicles they've announced up to two and
a half billion pounds in blind these are
important numbers sophie this is a this
is really happening people are actually
looking at an economy that's creating
jobs they're very very uh pleased about
that they're looking at the economy and
worried about their own budgets as well
aren't they looking at inflation at
seven percent they're worried about how
they're going to pay their energy bills
absolutely when are you going to come
back with an emergency budget there
won't be an emergency budget uh
obviously that's something uh for the
chancellor but he's rolling out no
imagination
it's not in my power to do that you know
as well as i do many of your viewers
that budgets are for the for the for the
chancellor all i'm saying is that
there's been considerable amount of
support already he's had a 9.1 billion
uh package at the beginning of this year
and in the spring statement there was
also a further five billion up to five
billion pounds uh to support uh the most
vulnerable uh customers and to support
people precisely uh to deal with the
cost of living so no need for an
emergency budget then it's up to the
chance of exchequer that's his uh that's
his job your job is energy of course and
business so you're urging uh oil and gas
companies to increase the investment in
the north sea what's the idea well the
idea there is that um they they're going
to be announcing profits uh they're
successful companies and i'm saying to
them you know it's it's great that you
are your british companies you're
successful uh british companies but it's
absolutely vital that you reinvest uh in
in britain particularly in gas so that
we have energy security but also without
gas we're not going to get the new
technologies we're not going to get uh
blue hydrogen what they call blue
hydrogen we're not going to be able to
do uh carbon capture which is a key part
of
the new uh greener economy and what
happens if they just ignore you and will
you impose a windfall tax on them well
i've never been uh a supporter of
winfield taxes i've been very clear
about that publicly i think that that
discourages investment and the reason
why we want to have investment is
because it creates jobs it creates
wealth and it also gives us energy
security so
it's vital that companies invest in the
uk and actually to be fair are you on
the same page as a chancellor on that
the reason that i ask is rishi sunak uh
said to mum's night this week in talking
about windfall tax what i would say is
that if we don't see that type of
investment coming forward and companies
are not going to make those investments
in our country in energy security then
of course that's something i would look
at and nothing is ever off the table in
these things so he's a chancellor he's
responsible for tax policy from my point
of view i want to see investment in the
north sea i really want to see
these assets developed and also driving
new technologies which are going to
green
our economy which are going to reduce
carbon emissions
technologies like carbon capture and in
order to get that going in order to get
jobs in order to get people uh working
in these exciting new technologies we
need investment and that investment is
going to come from the private sector it
sounds like you want to rule out the win
idea of a windfall tax but the
chancellor
doesn't want to do that my own view is
that and i've said this publicly many
times
a windfall tax will act as a
disincentive
uh to to invest and we want to see
investment we want to see developing our
own assets
not only for jobs but for energy
security okay uh thank you very much uh
for being on the program thank you
thank you thank you
uh well we've done the government we can
turn now to labor because we've got a
big week coming up for our next guest
the labour leader kier stama he's going
to be hoping to capitalize on the
government's much publicized
difficulties in next week's local
elections
now in mid-term elections like this the
quality quantum would argue that an
opposition would be expecting to inflict
some significant losses on a sitting
government so of course the scale and
spread of any labour gains will be a
crucial indicator of the party's chances
in a general election
well let's talk now to the leader of the
opposition sikhism who joins us now
thank you very much for being here uh
with us uh good to have you on the
programme um let's start with the local
elections uh shall we what would success
look like
well we've got a really good team of
candidates we've got a very positive
message we're laser liking our focus on
the issue that matters the cost of
living
crisis and we want to make gains we want
to hold the good seats that we've got we
want to make gains and so we go in a
very positive spirit i don't want to
predict what's going to happen but the
teams are in good shape and i can tell
you the cost of living issue is the
number one issue and
um the conversations that we've been
having wherever we are in the united
kingdom are essentially people saying to
us
i can't afford to pay my bills and i've
just got whacked for more tax by the
government the government has
response to the cost of living trust
been an abject failure
and we've got a very positive uh
proposition to put on the table so what
we're saying in these elections is send
a message to the government about their
total and abject failure in relation to
cost of living
vote for a party that's got an
alternative a plan to deal with what
matters most the thing that's keeping
you up at night um and vote for a party
that's on your side okay that's the uh
pitch um you say you want to make a game
that's the argument we've been making
across the country for the last i don't
know how many weeks but it's great to be
out there making that argument um so you
say you want to make gains could some of
those gains come in scotland do you
think you might leapfrog for
conservatives to come second there to
the snp well i've just come back from
scotland so i was up in scotland on
thursday and friday with anasawa our
brilliant leader up there
the team up there are in positive
spirits there have been some recent
suggestions that
we might uh overtake the conservatives
i'm very conscious that whether it's in
scotland or anywhere else in the country
um we have to earn every vote i'm not
taking anything for granted um i know
that we've got a lot of work to do from
where we landed in the last general
election um but we're working hard on
this and i think the main reason for
that is because
we have this
very practical response to the cost of
living crisis which is to say look oil
and gas companies in the north sea have
made more profit than they're expecting
we should tax that and use it towards
energy bills take up to 600 pounds off
for those that most need it and don't
impose a tax uh in the middle of a cost
of living crisis we'll talk a little bit
more like that
we'll talk a bit more about the vision
in a minute and but you know you're
saying that you started from a low base
uh after the last election results i
think everyone would agree with that at
the same time though you know the time
that most of these suits were last
fought was under jeremy corbyn in that
time we've seen a prime minister who has
been fined for breaking the law we've
seen a conservative mp this week who had
to resign after
being caught watching pornography in the
house of commons we've seen as you've
been talking about a cost of living
crisis you shouldn't just be hoping to
make a few gains should you shouldn't
you be absolutely storming ahead of the
conservatives in the polls and why
aren't you well look they are the dying
groans of a sort of clapped out
government i certainly accept that
whether it's owen patterson and the
scandal there whether it's partygate
whether it's the sleeves that they say
why aren't you smashing them in the
polls well what we've done we've gone
when i took over which was whatever it
was two years just over two years ago we
were over 20 points behind in the polls
and we'd lost a general election the
worst loss for us since 1935 and in two
years we've turned the labour party
around we've changed the labour party
nobody suggests that we haven't and
we've got ourselves into a position
where we've now got a poll lead so now
i'm just talking about perhaps being
able to make a few gains from where
jeremy corbyn did in 2018. in two years
that's a pretty extraordinary um
progress
we've got wind in our sails we're a
confident team i've got a fantastic
front bench out there now obviously you
know when the next general election
comes whether it's next year or the year
after we've got more work to do into
there but to have gone from where we
were when i picked up the labour party
and the leadership of the labour party
to where we are now is considerable
progress more work to do of course i'm
gonna we're gonna fight for every vote
in these general elections i go nowhere
expecting people to vote for labor got
to put our positive case on the table
say what we would do about the cost of
living crisis
and i have to scout all the papers this
morning as you would have done i didn't
see a single thing from the government
about what they're going to do about the
cost of living trust well let's talk
about that
let me just finish on the local
elections because the conservative
chairman has accused you of a secret
pact with the lib dems on the front page
of the mail on sunday you probably saw
it when you were scouring the paper i
did
standing aside candidates where the lib
dems are strong and vice versa to avoid
splitting the ntutori vote now in the
south west
you're standing candidates in 61 of
seats compared to 97 in 2018. well look
um the first thing i'd say is i wouldn't
take anything oliver dowd and says
particularly seriously and the fact that
he is spending his
sunday opportunity
um to speak to the public attacking
labour on some part why doesn't he say
something about cost of living crisis is
it is it is it true is it true i know
you're trying i know there's no there's
no pact everybody knows there's no pack
we will put a candidate up um if there's
a when there is a by-election obviously
after the neil parish um resignation of
yesterday um but what we're doing is
focusing on you so many fewer
candidates in seats such as in the
southwest i think and i'll happily have
this checked out that we are standing
more cat labor candidates in this
election than we've ever stood um now
i'm recalling a statistic in the back of
my mind but i'm pretty sure we've got
more candidates out there than we've
ever put in the field before we're very
you know we're out there i've got teams
working across the country we're
positive we're laser focused on the cost
of living crisis and all you've got from
the government is mudslinging left right
and center whether it's angela rayner
whether it's oliver dowd and talking
about pact okay why aren't they talking
about the issue that matters everybody
knows that people are worried about
paying their bills what what's the
government got to say about that
absolutely nothing other than we're
going to tax you in the middle of a cost
of living crisis well let's let's talk
about that shall we because it's clear
that you want to talk about the cost of
living in christ
i can tell that you want to get into the
number one issue answer
what is the number one thing you would
do to stop and i and and i know you're
going to rattle off you know a few
things such as you know
taxing all companies a bit more not
putting up national insurance by the
same amount paying you pay a bit less on
your energy bills due to the vat cup but
i'm just wondering if these things are
big enough to meet the challenge of what
we're about to face what is the big idea
to tackle it well the immediate problem
that many people are facing is that
their energy bills have gone up by
hundreds of pounds and um i've had i'm
afraid too many examples of the human
impact of that a pensioner two weeks ago
with mobility problems aged 86 telling
me that she's too scared to put her
central heating on because of the bill
and she's got a sort of padded
gown that she sits in most of the day so
that's the immediate problem what's the
government done about it absolutely
what's going to do what's labour going
to do we're going to tax the oil and gas
companies in the north sea
in relation to their excess profit so
the profits they didn't expect to make
because the global price has been so
high and i hired quasi
and what are you going to do
then we're not talking about taxing the
profits they expected to make this is
the profits they didn't expect to make
we would then use that to reduce energy
bills by up to 600 pounds for those that
needed directly using that for the
energy bills now i can tell you this um
600 pounds
help with the energy bills for those
that need it would be desperately needed
and welcomed across the country we also
wouldn't introduce a tax a
self-defeating tax at the worst possible
time in the in the mid this week many
people got their pay slip and they'll
have looked at that and saw well the
bills are going up the pay slip is less
because the government's just whacked me
for even more tax in a cost of living
crisis um and so we've got practical
answers to what is the number one issue
as i go around the country and all of
our team's reporting this all the tory
teams will be reporting this back to
them as well what do they say five days
to go before the election what have they
said about the cost of living today
absolutely nothing okay um i want to
play a quick video uh it's an
endorsement that you've received uh
today uh from uh tony blair i think it
might be a little bit controversial with
some people in the left of the party
let's just have a little quick look
in strength
determination and intelligence in
setting labor back on a winning path
he knows a labour party true to its
principles
is a labour party dedicated to winning
power
i mean some on the left might be a bit
uncomfortable with this particular
endorsement
tony blair won three elections
um and
the labour party
doesn't win elections very often so i
think having the endorsement of tony
blair is is very important very valuable
and and and
i think
further demonstrates the amount of work
we've done in the last two years the
change that we've made but i'm very
happy to talk to and with someone who's
won three elections because i didn't
come into politics to be an opposition i
came into politics to win elections it's
strange because i remember interviewing
you during the leadership election and i
asked you if you thought you were
politically closer to jeremy corbyn or
to tony blair
uh now you wouldn't tell me you said i
can think myself i don't need to hug
jeremy corbyn i don't need to hug tony
blair or anyone else i have to say it
feels a lot like you're a lot more
comfortable hugging tony blair i can't
imagine you putting an endorsement video
for jeremy corbyn up you you took the
whip off him what i've said why didn't
you say at the time why weren't you
honest to say yeah actually i'm more
close to tony what i said at the time
what i've said consistently is um
the team now that we've got or the
leadership team you've got going inside
the question are you closer to tony
blair or jeremy let me just tell you
what i said at the time which was i'm
not going to hug any previous labour
leader because i don't believe that you
go backwards to go forward i will learn
from any labour leader i will talk with
any labour leader and if it's tony
player has won three elections gordon
brown who won it with them then i'll
happily take their advice and talk with
them but i've never been but i've never
suggested that we i think tony actually
in that endorsement or something he said
yesterday said we're not in the na in
the 1990s we're actually going to face
the future going forward so it's the
principles and approach that matter but
i you know
i spend my time talking to people who
win because i want to win i want to win
because i want to change the lives of
millions of people
don't tell me that in the leadership
election they did you i've i think in
the leadership i can't remember how many
times the leadership election um i said
i think i use this phrase saying i'm not
going to have the name of some previous
labour leader tattooed on my forehead i
have to take this party forward facing
the challenge that we've got now okay i
can't i'm not facing the challenges that
tony blair faced a quarter of a century
ago
um i'm not facing the challenge that
previous leaders faced i'm facing the
challenges of tomorrow and i'm
absolutely determined okay to not only
change the labour party but to change
britain in the work that we're doing
okay uh now i do need to ask you about
what happened in durham uh this is when
you were pictured drinking beer with
party activists ahead of a by-election
at the time of course people in england
were banned from uh mixing indoors apart
from uh at work there's a picture there
yeah lots of coverage of this was angela
rayna there yes
um we were
in the office we were working we paused
for something to eat there was no party
no rules were broken uh and that is the
long and the short of it and durham
police looked at it and decided there
was absolutely nothing wrong what we've
seen this week is lots of just we've got
an election now i know what's going on
here we've got election on thursday what
is going on and there's just tory mps
now that's trying to throw mud around
because they've got nothing to say on
the central issue of the cost living if
they focused as intensely on the cost of
living as they are on durham millions of
people would be saying you know good
thing too i understand your frustration
at this event being compared or or may
seem be equivalent to other lockdown
breaches i understand why struggle
that's the problem with that i struggle
look what i struggle with is why if
angela was there
you said that she wasn't then i would
let me just i don't i don't understand
why that would okay sophie
it was a mistake we made a mistake in
the office
it was a mistake it was a general
mistake why wasn't it corrected well you
see how it looks it just looks a bit
shifty even if it wasn't why didn't you
correct the mistake when you realized
we were asked twice um and
uh i didn't realize we've made a mistake
before until it came out this week it
was a j we're a busy office we made a
mistake it's a genuine mistake
um
and and let me i i take responsibility
for i run the office we we simply made a
mistake it's a genuine mistake i don't
think anybody would seriously say
kyo stama's team would lie to the media
about this we made a mistake we were the
media was told the wrong information and
it wasn't correct so if it was a you can
know this from from running offices
yourself from time to time a mistake is
made it's a genuine mistake um and i
take responsibility for that okay
uh now i want to talk to you finally uh
before we end just a little bit about
the sexism in westminster that we've
seen over the like the last few weeks
according to the sunday times more than
50 mps facing allegations of sexual
misconduct after being reported to a
parliamentary watchdog more than 50 the
papers are full of allegations from mps
licking researchers faces to
mps watching pornography in the house of
commons what is going on
let me take that slightly in stages
because there's no denying when you reel
off a series of um
examples like that there's a
cultural issue that we have to get to
grips with and culture change has to be
led from and modeled from the top
we need to listen to women
and i've spoken to a number of women in
the last few days about this
and they are
very clear that
whilst there does need to be culture
change um those who are engaged in this
sort of activity um whether it's
comments about angela rainer or whether
it's watching porn in the house of
commons
um have to take responsibility we can't
run this argument somehow this high
pressure cultured play a place
take responsibility neil parish chose to
watch porn in parliament
tory mps chose to make disparaging
comments about andrew arena they've got
to take responsibility neil parish to be
fair has taken responsibility he's
resigned yeah well then the third thing
is political leadership because what
we've seen from this government time and
again is when one of their own gets into
a difficulty in a problem because
they've done something they shouldn't
have done whether it's owen patterson
whether it's the wakefield mp or whether
it's neil parish their first instinct is
to push it off into the long grass
you know hide what's happening and that
is a political problem because a fish
rot from the head and there needs to be
political leadership on this as well and
we haven't seen that from the
conservatives talking about political
leadership and it's got to be quite
brief because i've been told in my year
that i'm out of time but i do want to
squeeze this last one in what actually
needs to happen should we be looking at
closing bars in parliament should we be
looking at what the speakers uh wants to
see mps perhaps not being able to
directly employ staff what actually
needs to happen behavioral change that
we all have to contribute to uh cultural
change taking responsibility
i understand all these words but but
what's
what specifically
needs to change well
where an individual um is involved in
these sorts of behaviors they need to
take absolute responsibility straight
away with neil parish no no but sorry
i'm just asking for like a specific
thing like like for example you know do
we need to look at the employment at
legislation well do we need to close
bars do we have voters for female mps i
think i mean the speaker's suggesting
that there's some sort of review the
independent process we put in place is a
good thing and i'm supporting and
supportive of that um the speaker i
think wants to pull parties together to
see what else can be done i'm very happy
to participate in that because we can't
go on
with these allegations coming out over
and over again it feels a bit
frustrating to me i have to say you and
also quasi quantum coming in lots of
strong words about misogyny but i just
can't see any actual practical
suggestions for what can change rather
than like oh we need to be better well
there are practical things i mean the
independent process is good we'll talk
to the speaker about what else can be
done but sophie when i've dealt with
cultural change before and i had to do
this within the crown prosecution
service
i i learned that it has to be led from a
model from the top people look to the
political leadership see what approach
they're taking
and you know without that i think it's
very difficult to bring about change
thank you we're out of time chris darma
thank you very much for being on the
program uh today
uh labour leader uh kistama uh there
well we can now talk to the liberal
democrat leader
ed davey who is of course campaigning
ahead of those local elections are good
to see now mr davey so what does a good
set of election results look like for
the local for the lib dems next week
well i've been going up and down the
country talking to people
and there's no doubt that they are
extremely
cross and disappointed with the
conservatives lifelong conservative
voters feel they're being taken for
granted they're really worried about the
cost of living crisis
alarm that the conservatives responses
to
increased taxes on them and it looks
like boris johnson doesn't care and
doesn't have a plan and liberal
democrats are saying this should be a
big tax cut for people and that is going
down well so how that works out i'm not
sure but i do think we'll make progress
and i do think people are switching to
the liberal democrats
um so you think you make progress you
think people are switching to the lib
dems um we were talking to the labour
leader kirsten there he denied any kind
of electoral pact going on with the
liberal democrats but if you look at the
numbers i guess people will wonder if
there is some kind of quiet alliance
going on in the north east for example
you're standing in 56 percent of seats
compared to 78 four years ago that's an
area where labour's standing in 99 of
seeds
is there some kind of pack going on and
to be frank you know some on the left
might think that's a very good idea
listen there's no pack now there's not
going to be a pact in the future uh the
democrats are actually fighting labour
in many areas in hull in sunderland in
sheffield in haringey in southercon uh i
can take you to many other places where
there's a real fight and you know these
council numbers i think are a bit of a
distraction and pretty desperate from
the conservatives let's remember they
always fluctuate from election to
election and actually conservatives are
uh fielding uh over a hundred fewer
candidates this time
okay uh thank you and now i'm interested
to know about a by-election uh coming up
as well uh one that you might be eyeing
up slightly neil parish of course we
talked about him this morning the mp
who's resigned uh over the allegations
or actually i shouldn't even say
allegations anymore because he's
admitted it to watching pornography in
the house of commons
he of course is the mp for tibetan and
homerton
is that a bilateral you think you could
win
well first of all i'm really
pleased that he's resigned it was
utterly unacceptable it's right that he
he went it took a little bit longer than
i'd like but it's right he's gone so
there will be a by-election in tiverton
and hunterton and i believe the liberal
democrats can be the real challenges in
that we have a real legacy of success
across the southwest
we've shown in the north rupture by
election where we were third at the
previous general election but we uh beat
the conservatives no one gave us a
chance but in those rural communities
across north shropshire we found
lifelong conservatives feel that they've
been taken for granted that things like
this health service they they felt the
conservatives were betraying and so in
those rural communities i think liberal
democrats can make real real uh inroads
and strides so uh i'm looking forward to
that by election i think we will be
challenging the conservatives hard
it's interesting isn't it because it
does feel like you are really trying to
target some of those true blue shires
you and i will remember the absolute
drubbing
that the liberal democrats got at the
hands of the conservatives after of
course going into that coalition
is this the first signs
that things are rebuilding or could this
be yet another false dorm because let's
be frank we we've had all these
optimistic chats before i've interviewed
lots of lib dem leaders with smiles on
their faces before
and then it all comes crumbling to
nothing at the ballot box
well to be fair sophie we've been
building steadily over the last two
years if you look at our local election
results i was proud of what we achieved
in may last year and then of course we
had those two historic by-election
victories in true blue buckinghamshire
uh in cheshire and amisham where no one
expected the liberal democrats to beat
the conservatives but we did and i
talked about the blue wall across the
southeast where we're challenging lots
of conservative mps and then the north
shropshire by-election a seat that
converted hell for 200 years and then if
you look at council by-elections this
year across the whole of the country
which party's been winning the most it's
been the liberal democrats so there is
steady success and i hope next thursday
we can build that and make make
more progress
and go taking that into the general
election now if we want to get boris
johnson out of downing street which
liberal democrats really want to do
only the little democrats can beat the
conservatives in many many seats
and we we have to be part of that
ejection of the conservatives and given
their failing to help millions of
pensioners and families with a
cost-living crisis
they don't seem to have any plan at all
they don't seem to care
liberal democrats have a real plan with
this
bold tax cut that's vat tax cut worth
600 pounds on average to to families
across the country i think people are
looking to us now as an opposition to
the tourists in many of their heartland
seats
okay and i want to talk to you a little
bit about uh the misogyny stories we've
seen in westminster we've been talking
about a lot on the show today
and it's everything from inappropriate
behavior in house of commons bars
to junior members of staff being badly
treated to of course the infamous
example of an mp watching pornography in
the house of
commons i'll be i'll level with you i've
been slightly frustrated by the lack of
concrete suggestions put forward by
guests so far uh this morning lots of
big words but perhaps not in the way of
actual concrete changes
that can be made what do you think needs
to happen specifically
to stop us having to have the same
conversation about misogyny in the
commons every couple of years
well sophie you're absolutely right this
has been going on far too long and
this appalling behavior that we're
seeing is unacceptable misogyny the
sexism the treatment for example angela
reyna this is gonna put women and girls
off and coming to our politics that's
damaging to our country so we've got to
act let me give you one or two concrete
examples we should be looking at how mps
employ their staff
some people have been putting that
forward let's look at that properly
that's a concrete example look at the
independent complaint system although
it's relatively new and i strongly
support it there are concerns that it's
too slow
let's speed that up and give staff and
other mps confidence that action will be
taken quickly and not and things not
just kicked into the long grass we have
to restore confidence we have to
get rid of this appalling misogyny
and sexism in our politics and frankly
in our wider society
we've got to respect women and girls far
more we've got to show them with
concrete actions that's what we are
going to do
talking concrete actions would you be in
favor of quotas for female mps or
perhaps shutting bars in the house of
commons
well um
i'd have to look at everything i i'm
very proud that i lead a liberal
democrat parliamentary party which has
majority women uh
over two-thirds of our
mps in parliament for the liberal
democrats are women and we've managed to
do that without quotas
and i'm determined to make sure that we
are as diverse as possible as a palm
tree party
and you know we need to make progress um
i'm happy to look at any measures and
have that discussion
but i'm pleased the liberal democrats
have already made made real progress
okay uh thank you very much ed davey
they're the leader of the liberal
democrats
well continuing our rattling through
leaders of political parties the local
elections are also of course a crucial
shock window for the greens
climate change dominating the news in
the run-up to cop late last year but it
has a focus on the cost of living in
ukraine pushed it down the agenda well
we can speak now to the leader a
co-leader i should say of the green
party agent ramsey thank you very much
for being with us
so what would success look like for the
green party next week
well the green party has trebled its
number of councillors across the country
in recent years more greens leading
change in our communities and seats
we've won from all the other parties
right across the country so success this
time will mean more greens elected right
across the country we're confident that
will be from labour and the
conservatives we're confident we'll see
big strides forward including in places
where we already have good numbers of
councillors and expect to see more
places like reading and burnley and
south tyneside and also other places
where there's currently not a strong
challenge to the incumbent so if you
look at london boroughs like islington
like newham like hackney where there's
very little challenge to the labour
administration greens are actively
challenging on the ground and look to
get
we look set to get opposition
councillors elected to be
having a green in the room that can make
a big difference to the debate as well
as being champions for local communities
it does feel like sorry uh one of the
quiet stories of the last few years has
been the steady improvements of the
green party you made a neck sorry excuse
me
the green spent a net gain of 88
councillors for example in 2021.
at the same time though this has been
off the back of labour doing slightly
disappointingly in the polls are you not
concerned that as labour
comes into a stronger uh performance in
the polls ahead of these elections it
could be at the expense of you
the response we're getting on the
doorstep is that at a time when we're
seeing so many scandals in westminster
people are looking for an alternative to
the established political parties and
a fresh voice
to provide an alternative to that
establishment and that's what greens are
offering practical improvements that can
make a real difference to people's
everyday lives as well as a healthier
environment and we have made a real
progress against labor as you say and
interestingly in last year's local
elections as you say record gains for
the greens most of which were actually
gains from the conservatives so we are
winning from all the other parties right
across the country and we're confident
of more strides forward this time around
i just wanted to talk a little bit about
your foreign policy because it feels as
if the
defense and foreign policy land
landshape has completely shifted this
year with the invasion of ukraine
with russia of course a country with
nuclear weapons being so aggressive in
its invasion of another
country
as well and many of those countries nato
members included places like poland
being very concerned about their own
security going forward
do the greens still want to take the
united kingdom out of nato
so we have a
long-term policy that's about reviewing
what structures we need to have to build
peace in the world and we have to
remember this conflict has happened at
the time when we're part of nato and
where
where we still see nuclear weapons
dominate
of course we're not about changing
structures in the middle of a conflict
and what we need to do at the moment is
focus on how ukraine can be supported in
a wide variety of ways and that needs to
mean a greater focus on peacekeeping and
on getting the parties to the table
we're pleased the united nations has
started to do that but there needs to be
far more focus on bringing the parties
around the table and there needs to be
stronger economic action as well because
uh across europe we're still sending a
billion euros a day to vladimir putin's
war machine from buying russian oil gas
and coal and we need to wean ourselves
off this addiction as of course greens
want us to do
if we're to avoid funding that war
machine and really put strong economic
pressure on russia and that's really got
to be stepped up
and you said a lot in that um answer but
i didn't actually catch the answer to
the question itself which was did the
green party still want to take the
united kingdom out of nato
i think i did ask that sophie which is
that yes that is our long-term policy
that we would like to see
far greater focus on peacekeeping
institutions and institutions that
support a reduction in our nuclear
weapons and and
countries moving away from nuclear
weapons but in the short term of course
we're not proposing moving out of nato
in the middle of a conflict the focus
needs to be on international action that
brings pressure to bear on russia
through a variety of means including the
work of the united nations including
international cooperation in a variety
of ways and that must mean economic
pressure on russia through sanctions on
oil and gas okay thank you uh very much
uh there uh
leader co leader of the green party
thank you
well in a little while we are going to
be talking to the snp leader and the
first minister of scotland nicola
sturgeon but what are the nationalist
calls in wales we can talk now
to the leader of blood cumbria who is
adam price joins us now uh thank you
very much for being with us
morning
what are you hoping for in the local
elections uh next week it's been a
tricky few years for play comrade hasn't
it
uh well we're hoping to build on the uh
success that we've seen in the local
government with with pike country also
uh gaining uh uh um counselors in every
part of where's black camry means the
party of whales we want to be the party
of the whole of wales we have a strong
base uh in the former coalfield areas of
the valleys and also
in the western uh
half of wales but we want to see
that success actually flowing into
urban areas in the east of wales as well
as well as increasing the number of
councils on which we have a majority but
we lead four councils at the moment uh
but only one of them we have a majority
we'd like to see that uh uh grow further
this election and also what's what's
most important what is politics all
about it's actually using the the higher
number of councillors and the high
number of councils to make a difference
in people's lives so uh for example in
commanding show where i'm from we've uh
building uh
set to build almost a thousand council
houses now at a rate that we haven't
seen
uh in terms of council house building
programs since the 1970s that's the way
that we can respond positively and
constructively to the cost of living in
emergency we're seeing rent uh
increasing at over 10 percent a year in
wales one of the highest rates of
increase anywhere in the uk and on house
price rises as well str uh outstripping
local people's ability to get uh their
uh on that housing ladder the way that
we can respond to that is at local
government level building council houses
so that people have the option to stay
in their communities uh with affordable
rent
okay are you talking there about the
desire to try and do better in some of
those urban areas uh in cardiff for
example you've actually formed an
alliance there
of playa camry the greens and also
community campaigners standing under one
name the common ground alliance now of
course at the uh close of the last
council elections in cardiff played
country didn't have any counsellors at
all
are these alliances frankly the only way
you can get elected in some of these
areas
i i would say more positively sophie
because i i think and the response by
the way on the doorstep in cardiff has
been very very positive because people
people like cooperative politics uh they
look at you know what's going on at
westminster at the moment people are
looking for an alternative and they like
the idea of political parties uh even
though they may disagree in some areas
actually saying look
where we can work together for the
common good and find common ground and
surely that's a positive thing because
politics should be a about ultimately
trying to make a positive difference in
people's lives similarly at the national
level as you know sophie uh even though
we remain an opposition party in in the
senate we don't agree with the welsh
labor government in many things but
we've been we've shown a maturity you
know in the way that we do politics here
in wales by saying look just because we
don't this we don't agree on everything
doesn't mean that we can't agree on some
things and therefore make a difference
uh to uh people's lives particularly at
this time of the cost of living
emergency so for example we're
introducing universal free school meals
for all children at primary school level
why because we we have
tremendous problem with child hunger in
wales and child poverty incredible when
we you know quarter away through the
21st century isn't it we'd like to go
further in plank country what we've said
in the these local elections where we uh
form a majority on the council we will
start
taking the steps to move forward to
introduce universal free school meals at
secondary level as well so that we can
really make a difference to so many
children in wales that are sadly uh
facing poverty at the moment
okay and just finally you visited
ukraine earlier this year so you saw
firsthand uh the damage that putin's war
has done to that country
do you still want to leave nato and
scrap trident
an anti-nuclear party uh that's
absolutely uh essential uh i think in a
world nowhere as uh i think khrushchev's
granddaughter was saying uh uh only
yesterday we are closer to the
possibility of nuclear war than we've
been for many many generations and so we
need to to
ban those weapons of mass destruction in
the same way that we've done with
chemical and biological weapons but the
absolute priority at this point sophie
must be showing a practical solidarity
with the people of ukraine and what does
that mean that means a full economic
embargo which still isn't in place uh
you know we've got to get that full
economic embargo against the russian
estate and we have to uh i i think show
um a level of international leadership
that's been sadly lacking the un i think
has been
absent for a large part of this conflict
it was good to see the secretary general
uh uh visiting kiev recently we'd like
to see uh the emotion at the un general
assembly creating a un peacekeeping
mission as a means by which the
international community
can show practical uh means of
demonstrating solidarity with the people
we're out of time now uh thank you uh
very much adam price
well let's talk now to our final guest
the first minister of scotland nicola
sturgeon thank you very much for being
with us i want to start off by talking
to you about the local elections a
recent salvation poll suggesting the snp
could be on track for its best ever
performance what would success look like
for you
and also do you think that labour could
actually overtake the conservatives to
become the main opposition in scotland
well responding to the latter part of
your question first i i don't know what
i do know is that we have a situation in
scottish politics where labour and the
conservatives by their own admission are
still scrapping it out for second place
and i'm quite happy to leave them to do
that and concentrate on persuading
people across scotland again that they
should vote snp for good strong reasons
what would be a good result i want to
win the election i fight every election
hoping to win it but i take absolutely
nothing for granted i think voting snp
in this election firstly elects strong
snp councillors
elects snp councils that can work with
my government in hollywood to do
everything we can to help people
struggling with the cost of living right
now but the election is also an
opportunity to send a very clear and a
very loud and emphatic message to boris
johnson to tell boris johnson that
people are
disgusted at his antics and really
frustrated at his inaction and that of
the chancellor on the cost of living so
that's the opportunity people across
scotland indeed people in many parts of
the uk have on thursday
of course they might be voting on issues
a bit closer to home as well issues like
the uh recent controversy over two ferry
contracts in scotland 150 million pounds
over budget
five years late i mean often i think uh
to you know viewers across the country
you're seen as someone who's very on top
of the details someone who's competent
but to be honest i really don't
understand how buying two ferries can go
so badly wrong this is the
epitome of incompetence isn't it
well firstly to agree with you
on the point that people will vote on a
whole host of issues and people yes will
vote um and record the verdict on the
performance of me as first minister and
my government that's what elections are
about it's in the nature of energy
rightly said opinion polls suggest that
people will vote snp more than they will
vote for other parties but i don't take
that for granted on the ferries an issue
in terms of the delay to those two
ferries and the cost overrun something i
have expressed regret about we're
focused on making sure we deliver those
ferries the history of that issue of
course is that two ferries were procured
the shipyard in which they were being
constructed was in private ownership the
ferries it started to run over time and
over budget that private company the
shipyard then went into administration
and my government took it into public
ownership in order that we could
safeguard the future of commercial
shipbuilding on the river clyde and we
have secured that there are 400 people
working in that shipyard now earning a
wage supporting the families that
wouldn't be in those jobs but for the
decisions my government had taken and
we're focused now with new management at
that shipyard which is now of course in
public ownership to get those ferries
completed but i absolutely one of the
things i think it's important to do when
you're a leader is to concede when
things don't go right because in the
nature of government not everything goes
right all of the time and when things go
wrong you have to face up to that and
you have to focus on putting it right
and that's what we are doing on this
particular issue i think the other thing
that people are really concerned about
over what happened with the ferries is
the lack of paperwork so there isn't
paperwork showing why the scottish
government awarded the contract in the
first place to the ferguson shipyard
that's according the question
by
audit scotland which by the way was
against the advice of the public body
overseeing it the caledonian maritime
assets limited what happened to that
relevant paperwork was it not done or
was it lost
okay
well
the judgment of the auditor general who
of course heads up audit scotland and
was responsible for that report is that
this is a a single piece of
documentation amidst the 200 documents
the 1500 pages of documents that are
published that was not created that's
the judgment of the auditor journal to
be very clear
though
can you
well i was going to explain i was going
to explain what it was if you if you let
me finish on the 8th of october 2015 a
submission it went to a minister setting
out the concerns of simal the
organization you
referred to a moment ago and setting out
the mitigations that had been taken to
address those concerns the next day a
letter went from transport scotland to
seymour saying that ministers had taken
account of those risks and had decided
to proceed the piece of documentation
that apparently has not been created is
an email or a note in the middle of that
that would simply had it been created
have said something like the minister is
content on the basis of the
the reason set out on the 8th of october
so that's what is not there but anybody
who reads that and anybody can read it
if they're interested because it's all
published on the scottish government
website we'll be able to look at that in
its entirety and i think see at the
basis on which ministers took that
decision now that the the fact that that
piece of documentation is missing is
regrettable of course it is and we will
learn lessons but you know that is not
the reason the feds are over uh time and
over budget these are complex issues but
they are deeply regrettable issues not
least for
the island communities in scotland that
are waiting for those ferrys so as i say
you know it's important in positions of
leadership in government to recognize
that many things go right every day but
some things don't go right to
acknowledge that to learn lessons and to
put them right and i think the fact you
know 15 years into government we mark 15
years in government this week the fact
that so many people in scotland still
support the snp suggest that they
perhaps appreciate that candid approach
to government and still think we're
doing lots of things right that they
support and want to vote for
okay um are you still committed to a
referendum on scottish independence in
the second half of the parliament which
would mean next year
at the first half of the parliament to
be
about it which would you're right at
that point i mean the the end of next
year well these things if i had just
agreed with you there no doubt
lots of journalists trying to suggest
that i've changed my position but the
short answer question is yes
uh
russia i just want to um pick that
slightly russia a country of course with
nuclear weapons has invaded ukraine
and the world has obviously seen the
devastation that that has caused
is it still the snp policy that an
independent scotland should have no
nuclear weapons
i would want to see and this is
certainly the position of the snp and
independent scotland be a non-nuclear
member of nato um remember the vast
majority of countries in the world don't
have nuclear weapons and i think we're
seeing right now being reminded right
now of the dangers posed by nuclear
weapons but i would want an independent
scotland uh obvious that scotland is a
small country we have a strategically
important geographic position in the
north atlantic to be a constructive
and
participating member of nato and i think
one of the big
questions for my party indeed for those
who support an independent scotland is
to think in this new world order that
we're living in post the russian
invasion of ukraine where many of the
things we've taken for granted in the
post-cold war era have been turned in
their head we need to consider what
would an independent scotland bring to
that nato alliance and the question of
nato membership has not always been one
that
unifies everybody in the snp but i think
in the world we're living and it's very
important to recognize that would be
vital for the security of an independent
scotland and we would have a duty to
play our part in that broader security
arrangement
just specifically on the nuclear weapons
you say there that you don't see you
know future of scotland having nuclear
weapons of course the uk's nuclear
submarine base is at faz lane which is
30 miles from glasgow so would a vote
for scottish independence be a vote to
immediately effectively strip the uk
of its nuclear capability
well we've and i've said this many times
before and the snp has made this clear
we are a non-nuclear party and obviously
there is a big assumption until then
your question here that the snp would be
in government in an independent scotland
i hope that would be the case but i'm
speaking here for the policy of my party
but nuclear weapons are dangerous and we
would always be responsible in terms of
the negotiations around the timing and
the practical arrangements for the
removal of nuclear weapons from scotland
we would not be in any way irresponsible
about
that but we are a non-nuclear party and
we would want an independent scotland
and i think this is the point that is
sometimes in the discussions in scotland
forgotten the vast vast majority of
countries across the world are
non-nuclear the vast majority of nato
members are non-nuclear countries so
that is the norm but of course when
we're talking about dealing with nuclear
weapons the
we have to be utterly responsible in
everything we do but the snp is firmly a
believer in being non-nuclear but we
would want to be a very constructive
member of the nato security alliance
it's interesting uh listening to talk
because you know you're talking about
wanting to be a constructive member of
nato if of course scotland had become
independent as you say that's not
something that the s p has always agreed
on you say you want to get rid of
nuclear weapons but you want to do it in
a responsible way
speaking to you personally has what's
happened in ukraine
changed your thinking at all on some of
these big defense issues
uh yeah i mean i i think anybody who
would
uh say to you
that what has happened in ukraine in
recent weeks hasn't if not changed
fundamentally the thinking made them
question all sorts of things it would
not be somebody you would want in a
leadership position so yes and i think
very carefully about these things i
think
trying to get to a world that doesn't
have nuclear weapons actually seems to
me to be more important now not less
important but one of the things that um
i have become more certain of is that an
independent scotland for the security of
scotland but also for the security
of our part of the world would need to
be a fully constructive member of the
nato alliance the other thing that i
think we should all be reminded of is
how precious democracy is and how
important it is for all of us to be
prepared to stand up and defend
democracy i think putin has been allowed
you know through what he did in crimea
for example to get away with too much
for too long and i think we've all been
reminded that democracy is not something
that can just be taken for granted that
we've got to protect and defend it and
those of us who live in democracies in
countries like scotland where there is a
a vigorous and passionate debate about
whether or not scotland should become an
independent country we should actually
thank our lucky stars that we live in a
country where we can debate these things
democratically and decide these things
democratically whatever side we happen
to be on yes or no to scottish
independence that is something to be
celebrated so we all have to we are
seeing all sorts of things that we've
taken for granted since the end of the
cold war now being turned on their heads
and all of us of a duty at the european
union countries within the european
union are rethinking long-held positions
so none of us are immune from that but
we've got to do that in a way that
recognises core principles
but also recognizes the importance of
countries independent countries working
collaboratively together for the sake of
our collective security
okay i want to talk to you a little bit
about the stories and the allegations
that have been
emerging in westminster more than 50
mps apparently referred to the watchdog
for allegations of sexual misconduct we
of course saw the case of neil parish
who's now resigned for watching
pornography in the house of commons
now of course he has resigned but there
are allegations that have been reported
about some snp
mps as well aren't they
can you confirm whether or not the rgcs
parliament's watchdog has upheld a
complaint of sexual harassment about
patrick grady
i don't know i've seen what has been
reported as i understand that the
process is underway i have not seen any
findings and i'm not trying to dodge
this it's important that the process is
allowed to proceed uh when i do know
whether the
finally things have been upheld i'm
happy to come on and talk to you about
that and i'm happy to be open about what
i think should happen in those
circumstances but i don't know
what if anything has been upheld and it
would therefore be wrong and actually
not possible for me to go into detail
about that but what i will say is i i
think parties cannot simply throw stones
when it's people in other parties who
are being found guilty of these things
we all have to apply these standards to
ourselves and i will not shy away from
that when i do know what the outcome of
these processes are
okay um of course uh you're right to say
that they are allegations we don't know
you know the full facts at this stage
very important to say that and at the
same time though
if you are someone who you know is
always proud of themselves or on
rooting out sexism or on criticizing
other parties if you feel that they're
not doing the same
should someone not be suspended or have
the whip suspended while investigations
are ongoing
look these investigations are ongoing i
have it's not that long ago probably
around about this time last year i was
on your program and being rightly i hold
over the calls by you
in a journalistic sense of course uh
over the alex hammond allegations about
what i knew when and you know these
things are are difficult but i you know
ended up in a position where i was
subject to investigation there because i
wasn't prepared to see allegations
simply swept under the carpet so i agree
with you it's really important uh when
things conclude in a particular way for
parties to take responsibility for that
and act appropriately in this case
though the process is ongoing i don't
know
what if anything has been upheld and i'm
going to wait for that process to
conclude and then i'm happy to come back
on your program and talk about it in
detail at that point okay a bit more uh
widely uh should try and uh sort of get
get the bigger picture uh now uh on
misogyny and sexism directed towards
women in public life we of course
remember the coverage of angelina's
so-called basic instinct moment when she
was apparently just crossing and
crossing her legs you're no stranger to
run-ins about coverage of yourself by
certain newspapers i remember the
infamous front page of you and theresa
may
in the daily mail when you were talking
about brexit never mind brexit headline
who won legs it
um how big a problem is sexism towards
female politicians
it's a massive problem and
it's not getting better yet in fact in
some ways i think it's getting worse um
i think social media has made it worse
and is also made easier for those who
want to be sexist and misogynist towards
women in the public eye to have access
to them direct access to them and you
know i sometimes think speaking
personally and this is possibly wrong
i've been in politics so long i've been
subjected to that kind of stuff for so
long that i'm maybe personally a bit
nerd to it and and i shouldn't be um but
i am very conscious of the impact that
has on younger women you know we're
fighting a council election campaign and
i'm speaking for the snp here but i'm
pretty sure other parties would say the
same this election more than any
election i've been involved in certainly
any election have led to the snp and
it's been really difficult to get women
to come forward and stand for election
because there is a sense that politics
and public life is not a safe space for
women anymore and we need to do
something about that because we're going
to rue the day if we continue down this
path and women just don't see
the ability to come forward and be
active in politics so it's a real
problem in politics and in public life
but it's a societal problem sexism
misogyny and it's a spectrum from
inappropriate comments at one end of
that spectrum through to
serious sexual assault and murder at the
other end of that spectrum it's time to
draw a line in the sand you know not all
men are misogynist and we still feel the
need to say that but it's true but all
women
experience misogyny and it's a problem
of male behavior we've just had baroness
helena kennedy do a report for us in
scotland and she has proposed new
criminal laws
against misogyny which we're now taking
forward in the scottish parliament but
fundamentally this is about men
accepting that they are the problem and
changing and if we don't start to change
this quickly then the consequences and
the implications are going to be really
severe not just for politics but for
women in public life more generally okay
thank you very much for being on the
program today nicolas sturgeon there
thank you
now just before we go a reminder that
our weekly podcast is available every
week if you scan the qr code that you
can see on your screen right now you'll
be able to find the safety on sunday
podcast and subscribe so it's in your
feed each week you get them wherever you
get your podcast as well obviously but
there's some highlights of the
interviews a bit of post-match analysis
from the team here
it should give you a bit of an insight
effectively into how we put the program
together so find it subscribe wherever
you get your podcasts
well that is it for this week sophia on
sunday in a moment after the break we're
going to be running through today's
interviews seeing what we learned with
our deputy political editor sam coates
thank you for joining us this sunday
morning
[Music]
[Music]
okay let's go
[Music]
be
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to sophie ridge on
sunday the take this is where we're
going to be reflecting and giving some
thoughts on what we just heard over the
last hour we had a bumper uh show today
five uh political party leaders plus the
business secretary uh kwazii kwateng uh
and they also included the leader of the
labour party serkistama and the first
minister of scotland
sturgeon well there's one big story uh
dominating at westminster at that moment
at the moment and that is standards in
parliament and whether or not there is a
sexism a misogyny
problem in the house of commons lots of
allegations around
that i think we should be able to bring
in our deputy political editor
sam coats who joins us now just before
we hear what the politicians had to say
about it
it feels a little bit like we have this
conversation every couple of years
doesn't it about decrying the
the wrong doing if you like in
parliament the behavior in the bars the
sleaze um do you think anything's
different this time around
not particularly um what happens at
moments like this is that you get two
types of allegations you get some with
names attached and bluntly that's ended
up being the situation uh with neil
parrish the conservative mp who
announced he was standing down yesterday
his offense has been well played out
over the course of the last few days was
to look at tractor information online
and ended up accidentally looking at
pawn the first time and then the second
time voluntarily admitting that he
deliberately looked at pornography uh on
the uh houses of parliament estate and
for that he stood down yesterday uh in
the interview with the business
secretary you've just done uh quasi
quilting suggested that uh
neil patrick went down uh decided to
resign voluntarily up to a point lord
copper my conversation suggests that
pretty uh heavy pressure uh was applied
so um he wanted to stay on friday uh
pending the report that doesn't look
like uh he's where he ended up uh what
he ended up thinking yesterday um but
what is striking is what politicians are
prepared to do now in an environment
where nicola sturgeon told you uh that
politics doesn't necessarily feel like a
safe space for women but as i suspect
you found over the last hour or so
sophie squeezing concrete examples of
how things might change well that proved
rather hard yeah that's it i i'll admit
i was slightly frustrated uh by that
sound because it did feel as if uh both
of the uh politicians on the show or all
the politicians on the show were very
good
at uh criticizing the culture uh in uh
westminster saying that there was a
misogyny problem uh that things needed
to change people needed to take
responsibility but a lot softer on
actual concrete things that could be
done to change that
let's have a listen to what both the
business secretary and the labour leader
had to say on that issue
i think the problem we have
is that people are working in a really
uh intense environment uh there are long
hours
um and i think generally most people uh
know their limits they know how to act
respectfully but there are some
instances
where people don't frankly act uh
according to the highest standards is it
acceptable that there are so many bars
in the house of commons should they be
shut uh no they shouldn't all be shut i
don't think we should have a kind of
excessively puritanical or severe regime
in that regard i think again i would say
people should be expected to act
responsibly and if they don't we've got
we should have the process the procedure
to make sure that people are sanctioned
there's a
cultural issue that we have to get to
grips with and culture change has to be
led from and modeled from the top
we need to listen to women um and i've
spoken to a number of women in the last
few days about this
and they are
very clear that
whilst there does need to be culture
change
um those who are engaged in this sort of
activity um whether it's
comments about angela rainer or whether
it's watching porn in the house of
commons
have to take responsibility we can't run
this argument somehow this high pressure
cultured play a place
take responsibility
there you go
the uh responses there of kierstama and
quasi commanting to bring sam back in
it feels a little bit like they're just
hoping people behave
a bit better and that's it
i mean that's right
it sounded there from the way the two uh
men were just talking like they were
saying sort of different things
quasiquatting suggesting that much of
this bad behavior down to the high
pressure environment uh of the houses of
parliament uh whereas kierstama
suggesting that people just needed to
take more individual responsibility we
couldn't just excuse it through um uh
through the nature of the work of mps i
mean in truth sophie i think it's
possible to hold uh two things
simultaneously in your head both that
working as an mp is unusual you're away
from home for several days of the week
you're in a environment that involves
late night activity late night work
and there is some element of socializing
inevitably with being
away from home uh for many mps and
that's part parcel of it um but also
that there is absolutely no reason and
no excuse for the kind of uh behavior
that we're reading about in the uh this
morning's papers and i've been talking
about uh frankly for all the time that
i've been covering uh politics the
question is what you do about it uh and
you just look at the list of things that
quasi quatting ran through he said uh as
for all women shortlist he wasn't a fan
of that and i have to say uh the front
page uh headline on the sunday telegraph
suggesting that stories are going to
have half
female candidates that looked like a bit
of a stretch given the quotes that
oliver dowden give it uh gave to that
paper it might be quite a long process
before we see anything like that
quasi-quality not in favor of closing
the bars in the houses of parliament
kiyostama didn't leap on anything like
that either and whilst there was some
warm words around looking again at hr
processes i didn't detect any
enthusiasm to stop the basic point that
mps appoint hire and fire uh their own
staff in their offices and frankly if
they weren't to do that then life would
become quite a lot more difficult
because they wouldn't want people that
they didn't want to see in their offices
working for them so i don't know where
we go from here we've had this
conversation uh all the time that i've
been uh working in westminster there is
no silver bullet for it but i think a
lot of members of the public just look
at stories like this about mps and
wondered why can't they do better yeah i
think that's certainly it's that and i
think that's definitely the
uh what i took from those interviews as
well not least the oliver dowden quotes
when i first saw
the 50 line i was like wow this is a
this is big story we need to get stuck
into it on the program but then i was
like oh maybe not uh sounds much more
like an ambition uh rather a few warm
words rather than anything else and sam
uh we'll come back to you in just a
moment but i did want to just uh
introduce our next
uh take uh from safety ridge on sunday
because we talked to the business
secretary as we've been discussing he's
written to north sea uh oil firms
calling on them to invest their profits
into accelerating domestic energy
production now this is all of course
part of the cost of living crisis and
the soaring energy prices that so many
of us in fact all of us are experiencing
now let's have a little listen to see
what he had to say on where how far the
government is prepared to go
it's it's great that you are your
british companies you're successful uh
british companies but it's absolutely
vital that you reinvest uh in in britain
particularly in gas so that we have
energy security but also without gas
we're not going to get the new
technologies we're not going to get uh
blue hydrogen what they call blue
hydrogen we're not going to be able to
do
uh carbon capture which is a key part of
the new uh greener economy and what
happens if they just ignore you and will
you impose a windfall tax on them well
i've never been
a supporter of winfield taxes i've been
very clear about that publicly i think
that that discourages investment and the
reason why we want to have investment is
because it creates jobs it creates
wealth and it also gives us uh energy
security
well let's bring in our deputy political
correspondent uh sam coat shall we um it
felt like there was a little bit tom
picked there didn't it what where do you
feel do you feel there's a little split
in cabinet perhaps forming here
absolutely kids time i wanted everybody
to talk about the cost of living and
actually when we talk about the cost of
living we're talking about energy bills
energy prices and it is extraordinary
that we're a week before a set of local
elections and really there is division
in government um about how to handle the
situation that the
circumstances were in with energy bills
going up because the bottom line sophie
is that bills are going up an
extraordinary amount not just the amount
they've already gone up but we could be
talking about bills on average of maybe
four and a half thousand pounds a year
for the typical family uh in a year or
so if uh current trends continue and
that is unaffordable
and at the moment the question for the
conservatives is what are they going to
do about it rishi sunak floated the idea
of a windfall tax
last week with mum's net as you were
saying but interestingly behind the
scenes killed it shot it down in private
his age shot it down in private almost
immediately now quasi quatting shot it
down in public labor of course calling
for it you have a situation where some
of these companies are making a great
deal of excess profits because of the
price of gas and if they are getting you
know a windfall that they weren't
expected uh labor clearly making the
argument that it's fair to uh try and
redistribute that amongst bill payers
but the conservatives say that the
companies need to voluntarily use that
cash to invest more but with big profits
figures coming in the next few days
i suspect that they will come under more
pressure i feel like we're at the start
of the cost of living argument one of
the most bizarre moments last week in
politics was downing street press
releasing uh on monday night that they
were going to ask members of the cabinet
to come up with more ideas for cost of
living and then a sort of rather second
rate discussion in cabinet where there
was a bit of suggestion of rolling back
on national insurance a bit of
discussion about uh maybe getting rid of
some net zero um targets and then um
those being shot down and nothing much
happening it really feels like there is
a sense of scrabbling around in
government
over uh what to do about energy bills
and i think the split over what to do
about a windfall tax um is perhaps one
of the most prominent and the most
important labor know that and they're
trying to mine that division i have
fascinating stuff yeah we did definitely
see kirsten we're trying to shoehorn
cost of living into literally every
answer he gave us today and you can see
why if you look at what is about to
happen to people across the country or
what is already happening to people sam
thank you for your analysis as always a
good talk uh sound coaster deputy
political editor well it's been a big uh
safer ridge on sunday at this week our
final one before the local elections and
that's why of course you whizzed you
through i did a bit of a a a
rocket ship tour i guess of all those
different uh party leaders this morning
on the programme
this time next week we will know the
results of the local elections and they
are very significant not least of course
because
people are electing uh their assembly
members in northern ireland it could be
the first time
that the nationalists get a majority
there but also because what happens
locally in the uk is going to be seen as
a referendum on boris johnson how will
he do
big questions to answer
see you next week it has been a pleasure
as always the podcast of course will
follow around lunchtime today
[Music]
okay let's go
[Music]